[Música]
el moral
[Aplausos]
bueno bienvenidos a mi charla people no
sé si es lunes jueves viernes sábado
domingo me da igual lo que queremos es
divertirnos eso que habéis escuchado es
más o menos el saludo de mi canal de
youtube disturbe play for promo on
suscribiros si queréis bueno y mediamos
joel moral y tengo 10 años y aunque se
ahorraron un niño desde los 2 me encanta
todo lo relacionado con el terror los
maquillajes fx y el cine y la música de
otras épocas
preferentemente lo de los años 80
evidentemente me encanta stranger things
y tuve el dinerillo que ganó con los
trabajos o con lo que me dan por mi
cumple pero gasto evolucionando funk o
pops pero están a punto de echarme de
casa porque hace nada invadió el salón
bueno creo que todo empezó con poco más
de dos años todos los niños de mi edad
como nativos digitales que somos hemos
nacido ya con una tablet ordenador cerca
de nosotros y me encantaba estar
deprimiendo el portátil al principio me
ponía en las cantidades de los
cantajuegos los que seis padres lo
habrían sufrido
pero a mí un día mi madre me decidió
poner dos canciones de michael jackson y
esta fue mi respuesta
[Aplausos]
las madrugás
me convertí en fan incondicional de
michael de tal forma de que me enteré
que había fallecido dos años después de
su muerte porque no se atrevían a
contármelo
más tarde decidieron ponerme el vídeo
musical de thriller pero con cuidado por
si me daba miedo y de repente me flipó
me quedé totalmente alucinado me lo
tuvieron que poner en bucle porque
cuando acababa siempre decía más más y
desde entonces me flipa todo lo
relacionado con el terror y con la buena
música bueno este es uno de mis primeros
dibujos un poco más elaborados y creo
que si no psiquiatra viera lo que me
gustan estas cosas y lo que dibujo mío
vegan interno como psicópata aunque
bueno a la salida no voy a estar
esperando precisamente en el colegio un
día nos pidieron que dibujara moss las
herramientas que podríamos dibujar en
nuestro futuro trabajo yo dibujé esto y
diréis para que este niño dibuja una
biblia y agua bendita bueno es muy fácil
y básicamente es que yo quería ser
exorcista
después mi padre me dijo que antes de
ser exorcista tenía que ser cura y ya me
dio pereza
vosotros sabéis vosotros me avisa mi
cara del cura
no bueno yo creo que internet es
bellísimo y también es gigante podemos
aprender un montón de cosas o explorando
es cierto que es blando podemos
encontrar cosas que no debemos pero si
somos medianamente responsables y
nuestros padres están pendientes de lo
que hacemos podemos aprender mucho otras
personas
creo que el conocimiento están las
personas no sólo en los libros bueno
vamos a hablar bueno os voy a contar
mejor dicho el aprendizaje en internet
bueno como aprende lo que deseen
tutoriales consejos todo es en internet
música que sabríamos de música si sólo
escuchamos lo que ponen por la radio o
lo que emiten por la tele a nosotros una
temporada en el colegio nos dieron a
elegir canciones que podríamos poner al
final de las clases y bueno yo elegir un
tema maravilloso como fred i'm love the
cure y bueno os imagináis el suplicio
que fue para mí escuchar un día tras
otro un reggaeton y demás y además
siendo 25 niños en mi clase y además y
además también era
y además también era la misma canción de
moda todo el rato así que bueno menos
mal que tengo youtube isaza más para
identificar la música que me gusta y
spotify para tenerla siempre a mano
bueno como aprender a tocar una canción
bueno yo tengo un teclado en mi casa que
es de mi padre y busqué en youtube
cuando ya era más mayor como tocar el
exorcista porque no y bueno empecé con
el teclado de mi padre como ya he dicho
a empezar a practicar y tal y al final
esto es lo que me salió
[Música]
como hacer diseños para carátula bueno
yo descubrí dos aplicaciones gratuitas
que se llamaban camba y pixel r y
aprendí a utilizarlas también aprendí a
cómo organizar la música en shazam en
youtube y a guardarla en spotify
bueno os voy a contar mi faceta como
empresario y como youtube
yo quería hacer algún negocio pero que
también me motiva se así podría
comprarme más banco pop que es cierto
que internet te puede ayudar mucho
también a ahorrar porque por ejemplo
encuentro por amazon un producto de funk
o que vale yo que sé 16 euros y busco
por páginas de todo el mundo y a lo
mejor me sale por la mitad por ocho
euros entonces es como un dos por uno
está bastante bien bueno volviendo al
negocio que me desvío había visto los
niños vendiendo limonadas por los eeuu
con lo de la bici el del garaje pero
donde hago yo eso en el descansillo de
mi comunidad además lo de la limonada ya
está muy visto sólo puede defender en
verano y además no tiene muchas
posibilidades de innovación descubrió un
producto que me hacía mucha gracia y que
estaba empezando a funcionar es line
moco de gorila o como dice mi padre es
blandi blog de toda la vida me propuse
que comprarlo no sería una buena opción
y seguí que tenía que crearlo donde
podría saber más sobre el tema
en internet así que vi mis vídeos de
youtube pero cuando intentaba realizarlo
siempre me fallaba me doy cuenta de que
los vídeos tenía siempre cortes aunque
probablemente no decían siempre la
verdad estuve tres semanas probando
fórmulas diferentes hasta que di con la
fórmula exacta después no vea
haciéndolos de colores al gusto haciendo
los grandes vamos a tu gusto después
siendo ver haciendo los colores pasteles
croché con gente e imitaciones de
productos si eso que veis es un slide lo
que pasa que está metido en un vaso del
starbucks después me propuse venderlo en
el colegio pero también me di cuenta de
que podía tener muchos problemas cree
para evitarlo creó un contrato en el que
los padres deban su aprobación y ponía
su firma así no habría ningún problema
bueno después los profesores no pusieron
pegas pero cuando empecé a tener muchos
como se dice clientes muchos pedidos
pues me pidieron que no lo hiciera
dentro del centro regulaciones
restrictivas de importación y
exportación así que me propuse
así me propuse venderlo en la puerta
pero por fuera a veces hay que rozar el
vacío legal para poder hacer negocios
bueno de nuevo debería dar un salto en
la promoción de internet youtube me
ayudarían a través de mi canal rodhe
cómo hacer un slide en un vídeos en
cortes para que se viera que era
totalmente real eso me dio la solvencia
necesaria para crear más unidades y
gracias a amazon consiguió un bote de
cola más grande que resolviera la
demanda creo que saturaba el mercado del
colegio así que estoy buscando nuevos
mercados de nuevo internet me ayudaría
descubrí una página web que se llamaba
xxi donde la gente podría crear sus
productos y vendérselos al público estoy
pensando en plantar mis productos ahí
pero antes mi padre me ha dicho que
visite dos webs que están bastante bien
y que ayudan a emprender cualquier
negocio que son la web de agencia
tributaria
y la de seguridad social
tengo que pasarme por ellas en
definitiva internet es un portal el
mundo podemos encontrar todas las
respuestas a nuestras preguntas pero
como todo tiene una parte buena y una
mala y un superpoder te puede convertir
en un súper villano bueno superhéroe la
energía nuclear puede servir para
destrozar el mundo o para salvarlo pero
para eso están en la responsabilidad de
los padres y por supuesto a la nuestra
no hay que tener miedo solo controlarlo
y vosotros padres si vuestro hijo o hija
tiene inquietudes ayudarle a resolverlos
dándole acceso responsable de las redes
y vosotros niños si no lo conseguís así
de hacerles mamá papá de verdad internet
es mi amigo gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y